everyone's pedaling hard but andreas
littke is always just that little bit
faster it's like a Porsche compared to a
Ford Fiesta you get fresh air and it's
just cool he can accelerate from 0 to 25
kilometers an hour in seconds and that's
what gives it away prompting people to
pose the question it has a battery right
I say yeah there is the battery is
stored in the handlebar bag it powers
the motor in the rear wheel hub Andreas
has an electric bicycle he got rid of
his car a year ago as a hotel I switched
from car to bike because it's cheaper
and more environmentally friendly I
picked the ebike because I travel a lot
to see clients the bikes great because
you don't arrive at meetings all sweaty
and smelling I'd sagamu food in meeting
the event technicians spent three
thousand euros on a-z bike another of
its special features is that it's
collapsible so no matter where his
clients are andreas can reach them by
bike and train if necessary the bike
even fits in the trunk of a car she fits
clients often ask me how I get there's a
vast it's because I don't have to look
for parking lookin Partagas October
uncle whoosh ma also no longer worries
about parking she switched her family
estate car for a family ebike it's like
in them we've got two kids and it's just
more practical pulling 40 kilos behind
you on an e-bike that a normal bike you
can cover greater distances to when
normally you'd have to rely on the car
London's flight of audits of a caffeine
rotor with her ebike distances of 30
kilometers are no longer a problem the
only catch is the battery it runs out
after around 50 kilometers
this professional citizen in this I
imagined that the technology will
improve in the coming years but if you
want to take a longer trip you need to
take a second battery otherwise you
weren't make it but that didn't put off
300,000 Germans from buying electric
bikes last year a basic model costs
around a thousand euros they still
require a bit of physical effort of
course the motor only starts when
pressures exerted on the pedals biscuit
fascinas is there are various systems
most of them react emotion and pressure
on the pedals a specific pressure equals
a specific amount of power and that gets
transferred straight to the chain or the
rear wheel most ebikes have 500 watt
motors meany they can move almost as
fast as mopeds you can adjust the power
the motor adds to the power being
applied to the pedals most electric bike
buyers don't actually live in cities the
majority live in hilly regions
father-in-law blunt for bicycle dealers
in the country are happy because they're
doing a lot of business it's a bit
slower in urban areas we need
infrastructure for ebikes cities often
lack cycle paths or there's too much
traffic for not enough places to park
the bikes safely at night Germany is
Europe's biggest ebike market followed
by the Netherlands and Switzerland the
bike with the electric motor is booming
and could one day be a status symbol at
some point they'll start selling
all-terrain e-bikes or ones with
sapphire brakes I'm certain that it'll
be a status symbol at some point
you